c'est un silence pesant qui règne à
guayaquil
depuis plusieurs semaines la ville
estuaire est le lieu où le taux de
mortalité dû kovy 19 et le plus
important d'amérique latine
un bilan de 35 morts pour 100000
habitants toutes les couches sociales
sont touchées mais surtout les plus
précaires les habitants de la ville
assiste à des scènes d'horreur avec des
corps retrouvés dans les rues pour
limiter la propagation voya qu'il est
soumise à des mesures de confinement
particulièrement stricte avec un couvre
feu imposé 15 heures de suite
un bilan catastrophique qui n'est pas
près de s'arrêter comme l'a concédé le
ministre équatorien de la santé juan
carlos barrios
les experts médicaux nous ont
malheureusement 10 et estime qu'il y
aura de 2500 à 3500 morts dus qu'aux vie
de 19 au cours des prochains mois dans
la seule province du goyen nous nous y
préparons un nombre de morts
particulièrement élevé qui entraîne un
autre problème les décès s'accumulent et
les pompes funèbres se retrouve débordée
résultat des corps sans vie sont
abandonnés et la ville se retrouve dans
l'indignation et la peur mon frère vient
de mourir d'un problème respiratoire
il est là devant la maison s'il vous
plaît bonjour j'ai besoin de votre aide
mes parents sont décédés hier à 10
heures du matin s'il vous plaît regardez
comme je les garde
aidez moi nous sommes désespérés nous
avons aussi de la fièvre
à l'image de guayaquil
c'est tout l'équateur qui est fortement
touché par le virus depuis le début de
l'épidémie
quelque 180 personnes sont décédées et
plus de 3500 40 été officiellement
confirmés dans le pays